today we're going to talk about
object-oriented programming it's one of
the most common ways the software is
written these days certainly for things
like applications on desktops and mobile
devices prom with object-oriented
programming though is that it can be
quite difficult to get your head around
at first because it uses so many
different terms you talk about objects
sending messages to other objects
objects doing things you think they're
just bits of code how they doing
anything is on so it can be difficult to
get your head around it so Nicholas
Wirth who invented Pascal once described
programs as being algorithms plus data
structures now the data structures we
can think of as a sort of the data that
our program is manipulating whatever
that might be and the algorithms that's
basically the code that we're running to
manipulate that data one way we can
think about this is thinking about
something like a simple pong games or
all of the very early computer games you
got back in the 70s pong was a very
simple game that you played on your TV
it had some cuts your TV screen you had
a little batch on this side which one
person controlled you had another bat on
this side that another person controlled
and then you had a ball which was a
square block these literally were square
blocks that were filled in on the screen
so one player could control this and
move it up and down another player can
control this and move it up and down and
the ball would bounce between
effectively trying to be a sort of
tennis game the graphics were state of
the art for the time and you can still
find holes lying around mainly museums
it's one of the Computer History Museum
down in Cambridge if you were to go and
play with it so the pong game is very
very simple but we can use it to sort of
think about how the program would work
and so on and think so you've got two
bats and a ball and so the data for this
would be relatively simple this paddle
or bat over here you need to know where
it is so you need its position and we'll
call that its Y position and you'd
probably keep track of its X position as
well just to make it easier to draw
things and you need the same for this
one over here and again for the ball you
need the balls X paws and the balls Y
position so that's the data that our
program would represent it doesn't need
anything more than that really you
perhaps have some representation of the
screen but that be handled by the
computer so we'll ignore that for now
and we'd be able to write programs which
would use this data
to run the game so if a key was pressed
we would change the Y position to make
the bat go up or the different key was
pressed we changed this one's Y position
to make the bat go down and we could
change this to make the ball sort of
bounce off the edge of the screen so it
looks like the balls moving around so
I'm going to write some code very simply
to do this so we can say something like
if he said we're going to use Q to go up
is pressed then paddle one why pause
equals paddle one why X pause plus one
we could do something similar for the
going down for the same as we can write
this a program code that manipulate the
variables to move the paddles around
then we can redraw the screen so we read
on the screen it looks like the things
are moving actually all we've done is
change the variables data and then
redraw the screen this is okay in for a
simple program like this this approach
would work and anything else would
perhaps be over the top but often you
would find that you'd have lots of data
that you'd want to group together so for
example with a pong game we've got a
variable to hold the exhibition
available to hold the Y position a
variable to hold the balls x position
available to hold the ball Y position
and so on and we might as you say we're
talking a lot at the time about points
on things so we actually were to group
them together so we can use in various
programming levels they have the
facility to group things together as
what we call a data structure and we can
then refer to this position either as a
whole so we can set the position to be
the same as another position or we can
refer to the individual things inside it
so we can pass it into a function so to
draw the paddle just passing the whole
position in there but if we want to
update one of the values we can just
update that specific value like the y
position that we want to manipulate but
there's still a slight issue with this
sort of approach it makes it easier to
refer the things that we can have lots
of these data structures referring to
different things rather than having
separate variables here we could have a
position for paddle one and a position
for paddle two so we can refer to them
and have lots of them so we can have one
data structure which we can then have
many different things for so we can
actually group the data together which
is quite useful but the problem with all
of this is that the data is completely
open and we can write code anywhere in
our program
can manipulate it for a simple program
like palm having the data open is not a
problem the program is probably not
going to be more than a few hundred
lines long as the program grows you be
running something bigger then you'll
have lots of files accessing the data
and you might change some things and
forget to update part of the program so
for example you might update one part of
the program to only allow ten entries
rather than 100 in something but the
other part of the program still expects
100 and so it writes over the end walks
all over memory that's used for
something else so you get a crash your
pro might work so with object-oriented
programming we turn things on their head
slightly rather than thinking of the
program in terms of the code we write
and how it modifies the data we think
rather in terms of objects so what would
an object be while using our pond
example the objects in this game would
be well we've got two paddles in here so
we'd have objects that would represent
the paddles and we've got another object
here which is the ball so we can sort of
see what might be an object in their
program but the other thing we need to
think about rather than thinking about
writing code that manipulates the data
we need to think about what these
objects can do what operations can we
perform on them so for example on our
paddle we might have operations which
make it move up we might have an
operation that make it move down and
that would be the same for both paddles
and we could ask the object to perform
that operation based on input from the
keyboard so the ball object would be
similar rather than having operations to
move it up or to move it down we just
have an operation says update your
position we let the ball itself work out
how it's going going to move around the
screen the other thing we might have is
an operation to detect whether the ball
has collided with a paddle in this case
we'd say to the ball have you collided
with this other object so we'd have the
two objects working together to work out
whether they've collided now I've
described that and I've talked about
objects working with each other objects
having operations how does this all fit
down to the way it works with the
computer
well to do that we need to think about
what an object is and actually an object
is made up of three things so let's look
at the paddle
as an example to start with we'll think
about the ball in a minute it's got some
state and that's things like it's
exposition and its y position but you
might also if you taking this further
you might have something like the speed
associated with it as well and there
just be numerical values perhaps
integers floating point numbers
depending on the system they're using
they could also be other objects so we
could build an object out of other
objects but that's going to be an
advanced we'll look at that later on so
what we've got here is no different from
the data structures we talked about
earlier we've got some data and we've
encapsulated it together and we can
refer to it as a whole the other thing
that makes it different is that we also
have the operations and these are the
things that the object can do so if we
think about a paddle we said it would be
able to move up and we said it would be
able to move down we also said that you
might want to be able to draw it on the
screen so we'd have a draw operation as
well we might have other operations that
we need to make the prone word but these
are things like this we're going to want
to do to the object like making move up
or down so I have to have operations
allow us to get its position so we might
have a get position operation and that
might be used say by the ball object so
we can detect whether it's collided with
it or not and it's having these
operations which makes a difference
between a simple data structure and an
object we think about the state as being
the center of the object so we've got
that state that's our x position and our
Y position we'll keep it simple for now
for the paddle when we think about
things in an object-oriented way we say
no there's a defined interface that can
manipulate this data and so you have
this sort of ring fence around the data
so you've got the sort of move up
operation the move down the draw
operation and the get position operation
and the only way this data here can be
accessed or manipulated is by calling
these operations and these create what
we call the interface to the object you
can get its position which will give you
an XY coordinate we have worked out how
we returned that you can draw it and you
have to give it the screen you wanted to
be drawn on you can get it to move down
and you can get it to move up and so we
now write our programs not in terms of
manipulating
data but in terms of telling this object
to move up or to move down what actually
happens is when the move up operation is
performed there's a bit of code that we
specify here which updates the
y-variable
and then it returns back to whatever
called it to continue working so it's
actually a way of thinking about and the
way of structuring the program would you
prefer to say that's a small program in
its own right yes I mean that's that's
one way you can think about the object
is a small self-contained program that's
in its own right so it's got a move up
and move down it can be drawn and you
can get its position and then you'd
write another self-contained program for
the ball and that would pass up a
similar state but it would have
different operations associated with it
so the object is actually made up of
three things we've seen the state we've
seen the operations for the third thing
we have is actually not part of the
object research but we also have
identity and this is simply saying that
we can have many objects of the same
type so we can have one paddle like this
but we can also another or smaller one
for speed we can also have another one
with its state and the operations around
it and this can represent the other
paddle so we've got two objects with the
identical interfaces want to represent
the paddle on the Left want to represent
the paddle on the right so the only
thing that can alter the data is the
operation on the object of a particular
identity so if we wanted to access it we
say to an object with this identity
perform this operation and that will
then go and modify the state of that
object as I'm sure you've guessed we'd
have another type of object to represent
the ball which would also have an X and
a y position and it would have a
different set of operations around it so
some of them might be similar things
like we might have a draw operation but
we might have a collide operation
instead and then this time update
position subtly got an increased speed
operation as well as we have a speed
value in there the two objects that
represent the paddle at the same time
they have the same state associated with
them they have the same operations
associated with them but this one is of
a different type it's got different
state it's got an XY position and speed
and it also has
a different set of operations associated
with it and of course it has its own
entity and if we wanted to we could have
two balls in the game generally in most
object-oriented languages when we write
these things we define what we call a
class which is basically the blueprint
for building objects so it specifies
what operations they haven't provides
the code for those operations even
though it acts on each individual object
and it also specifies how the data is
stored and so on and then when we create
an object we create a new one with its
own identity with its own state and then
the operations can perform on that
individual object if we come to update
our program we talked about how that can
be a problem with structures how's it
easier here then because we've got this
defined interface for the object the
rest of the prom' didn't need to know
anything about how that object is
implemented so it doesn't need to know
there's a y-coordinate or next corner in
there all you need to know is to make it
move up it invokes the move up operation
on the object or it invokes the move
down to make it move down the beauty of
this is you have lots of different
classes of objects that implement this
interface and then you can drop in
whichever one you want so you could have
a paddle which is why there should just
be a different class of object and drop
that in you could have perhaps a
specialist paddle which was two paddles
that moved up and down in sync with each
other and you'd actually different class
of objects which you did you drop in
inside and this is part of what we call
inheritance in object-oriented
programming is one of the things which
can make it really powerful which we'll
look at in another video over a long
enough time scale I think that human
level artificial intelligence is
completely inevitable if you Angie hangs
around for long enough and continues to
progress in what it can do